Anything that really
scares you,
anything that intimidates you,
The end of my playing career
big time.
And when I'm playing football
during know,
seven months out of the year.
It's easier. You're focused.
You know, you got a goal.
You got something
you're trying to accomplish.
And when that's done
and you don't have 8000 people s
your name,
I mean, what's it going to be?
That was a baby.
That was baby Brady.
That was very it.
Baby Tom Brady
back in 2005,
reflecting on what
the end of his career could look
Well, here we are.
23 seasons in Indianapolis.
20 of them in New England.
He won six of his seven Super Bo
while he was with the Patriots.
Few people had a better at vanta
On Brady's
astonishing career
than the owner of the Patriots,
Robert Kraft, and he joins us no
Good morning, Bob. How are you d
Good morning.
Great to be with you on this top
Hey, Bob, have you spoken to Tom
Actually,
I we've talked a lot.
And he he plays
down the yesterday.
Not nothing about this.
Just, you know, it was the first
he had his two younger
children with them and
he really seemed happy
and they were happy.
And I
I loved it because his little da
well, both of those kids,
they call me archaic.
They say, we miss you.
We haven't seen you. And I was.
And, you know, it's just
Tommy is a fierce competitor,
but he brings love and
a great warm feeling to everythi
he does.
And here he is in his house
in a time like this.
And his kids are exuding love
to someone else and warm feeling
And that's what he did and does,
even in the huddle,
as fierce as a competitor as he
he gets people that come in
and be connected
as part of the team and feel ver
just for that.
I mean, we get in the interview
but we took
we told our viewers
no one had more insight than it'
And also for our viewers,
you might not know
you really loved him like a son.
That's how you described the rel
between the two of you guys. Rig
And I wonder if you can take us
because remember,
he was the you're
the owner of the Patriots
you guys draft him.
He's 199 draft pick
and then look what he turns out
and look what he does for the fr
Yeah.
I think the good thing for us
as the Patriots is
when he played in Michigan,
I don't think they realized
how special he was because
he should have been the number o
pick in the draft,
not one 99 in the sixth round.
And
when he came in to us,
you know, I never I'll share a s
it was near the end of training
and I was driving out
and he was coming down
the steps of our little building
he had a piece on Roseanne
from the food service.
And he came up to me and said, H
I'm Tom Brady.
I said, I know who you are.
You're a six
round draft pick for Michigan.
He looked me in the eye and he s
I'm the best choice you're franc
I'm the best decision
your franchise has ever made.
And I looked him in the eye
and you know, he just said it in
No, you you got to stand.
We just gave 100 million.
The biggest contract,
any quarterback to Drew Bledsoe
just before this a few months be
And he was number four in that s
He came down
and he really believed what he s
And he certainly did.
And he was right.
That's how you took the words
out of my mouth.
I was just going to going to say
Bob, you
did you wanted to retire this be
Did you think he should have com
this past season?
You know,
there are certain decisions in l
I always believe in giving couns
and trying to be supportive.
But
only an individual on his own
can make a decision like that.
They can ask
no one knows the different press
what alternatives are open to th
in this game,
how their body feels physically
whether there is something
that's dysfunctional
that won't allow them
to perform the way they want.
Because in the end,
the real competitors in
this game are playing the win ev
And if something's dysfunctional
in their body,
you know, they can take away fro
You know, we're a little bit
two week, less than two weeks aw
from the big game Super Bowl.
You guys got six
Super Bowl rings together
I wonder, was it Brady?
Was it Belichick?
Who was more responsible,
do you think,
for all those Super Bowl wins
Well,
when we
there's our 29th season
we just completed. Yeah.
And we were privileged
to go to ten Super Bowls
and win six of them.
And what I learned is
it's a lot of things it's,
it's probably
the sport of football and winnin
requires a team effort like noth
which is so important for our so
And you need
great stars like Belichick and B
but you need a lot of other peop
pulling in the same direction.
In the end, though,
to answer your question,
you can't win
if you don't have a good coach
and a good quarterback.
And then I was blessed
to have both of that,
probably the best
in the history of the game.
You know, I think back
whether there's over 25,000
or 30,000 players, we played foo
How lucky are we up here in New
To have the greatest that's ever
and really
played for us
for 20% of the history of the le
100 odd years.
I don't think
there are too many quarterbacks
played for one team.
Yeah, Bobby is so right
about having a great coach and t
Tom needed good people around hi
We talked to
yesterday to John Berman, who's
you know, Tom Brady superfan.
He said he just didn't
have the support
that he had around him
when he was with you guys.
My question, though, is
are there any plans, Bob,
to make sure that he retires?
Are you going to sign him
to a one day contract?
Do you want him back? Yeah,
to retire.
Patrick, do it
tomorrow for him to retire a.
No,
not only do I want it,
our fans are clamoring for it.
And to us,
he is always has been
and always will be a patriot.
And we will be bringing him back
after I have not
I don't like to make
a commitment for him,
but we will do everything in our
to bring him back
have him signed off as a patriot
and find ways to honor him
for many years to come
because he did so much
to bring life
and good cheer to our community.
And he's a beloved
figure, and he's earned the resp
and love that
people feel for him like no othe
in our town.
And we've had some great ones.
I think it's fair
probably to call that breaking n
I mean, sure.
Yeah, absolutely.
Lutely absolutely.
Well, it's
so nice to get to hear from you,
this morning.
Bob, before we go, you know,
I mean, look, he's like a son,
so what
you have this audience here on C
I know you're you're going to mi
I know you miss him
when he left the Patriots,
but you still were in contact,
contact with him. You love his f
What are your parting words?
Because I know you love him like
Well, try me.
I'm always here for you.
You're you are part of our famil
You know, and part of he was ble
having great parents.
His mom and dad are super people
He's got three
great sisters
and I was thinking about it.
He was the baby,
you know,
so to have four great women like
and then a role model and for hi
not to be super spoiled,
I don't know how it happened.
You know, out there in Californi
where everything is a little
different than it is here.
Your three feet. Yes.
We we we I tell you,
I just love the guys so much
and there isn't anything
I wouldn't do for him.
And I think
he can do
a lot of good things for America
and reach out to a lot of people
And thank you for the time
you gave us
and everyone here in the New Eng
region loves you and respects
you and wants happiness for you
and your life.
So well said.
Bob Kraft, we appreciate you. Th
Thanks, Bob. Good to see you. Be
Thanks, Poppy. Thanks, Don.
Great to talk to you both.